자, 오늘 우리가 만들어 볼 결과
보고서 시작해 보도록 할게요.
AI한테 시키면 알아서 끝까지 해주는
시대. 이게 바로 에이전틱
AI입니다. 기존 AI는 한 번
물으면 한 번 답하지만 에이전틱
AI는 스스로 계약을 세우고 도구를
쓰고 결과를 확인하면서 목표를 끝낼
때까지 반복합니다. 에이전틱 AI의네
가지 핵심은 이렇습니다. 첫째 목표
분해. 둘째 도구 사용 셋째 자기
검증 넷째 장기 기업. 가트너는
2028년이면 기업 의사 결정의
15%를 AI 에이전트가 자동으로
처리할 거라고 예측했습니다. 시장
규모는 2030년까지 연평균 45%씩
성장한다고 합니다. 이미 고객 응대,
코드 작성, 시장 조사처럼 사람의
하루 치일을 몇 분 만에 끝내는
에이전트들이 일하고 있습니다. 이제
AI는 다 파는 도구가 아니라 일하는
동료입니다. so easy.
안녕하세요. 코드 팩토리입니다. 자,
오늘은 하이퍼프레임과 AI를 활용한
영상 편집에 대해서 한번 이야기를 해
볼 건데 실제로 우리가 결과물을
내기도 낼 거지만 그 내용에 대해서
이야기를 한다기보다는 제가 어떻게
AI를 활용하고 어떤 문제가 생겼을
때 제가 어떤 방식으로 AI와 협업을
하는지 어떤 걸 중점으로 생각하는지
여러분한테 보여 줄 수 있는 좋은
계기가 됐으면 해서 이번 영상 한번
제작을 해 보게 됐어요. 자, 일단
하이퍼프레임이란게 뭐냐라고 얘기를
하면은 어, 영상 에디팅을 우리가
HTML로 할 수 있게 해 주는
툴이라고 생각하시면 될 것 같아요.
헤이젠이라는 굉장히 어, 유명한
아바타 제작하는 AI 아바타 제작하는
회사에서 오픈 소스로 만들어 준 건데
비슷한 걸로 이제 리모션 같은게
있습니다. 자, 이걸 쓰면 우리가 뭘
굉장히 적극적으로 할 수가 있냐면요.
아, 여러분이 요즘 유튜브 보면은이
AI테크 채널 중에서 얼굴 안 나오고
목소리만 나오는데 화면에 막
프레젠테이션 같은 애니메이션이
들어가는 형태의 채널들 본 적 있죠?
네. 전부 다 하이퍼프레임 아니면
리모션 같은 걸 썼다고 보시면
됩니다. 그거 손으로 다려고
하면은요. 엄청 오래 걸려요. 저는
해 봐가지고 알거든요. 자, 그런게
이제는 리모션이나 하이퍼프레임 같은
걸 사용해서 우리가 자동화를 할 수
있기 때문에 그런 채널들이 미친 듯이
지금 증식을 하고 있는 거고 여러분도
만약에 관심 있으면은 오늘이 영상
보고서 한번 작업을 해 보시면 될 거
같아요. 자, 그러면 우리가 한번
처음부터 한번 진행을 해 볼 건데
우리가 처음 작업을 할 땐 당연히
플랜 모드로 작업을 해 주는게 제일
좋겠죠. 자, 그리고이 중요한게
여러분이 결정하고 싶은 거는 꼭
정확히 말을 해 주고요. 그리고
만약에 여러분이 결정하지 않고서
AI가 결정을 했으면 하는 요소들은
그건 네가 결정해라고 말을 해 주는게
제일 좋습니다. 자, 그래서 우린
뭐라고 얘기를 할 거냐면요.
하이퍼프레임을 사용해서 영상을
편집하는 프로젝트를 만들 건데 어,
여러 개의 프로젝트를 우리가 동시에
관리할 수 있도록 폴더 구조를 알아서
네가 정해 주고 MP4 파일로 내가
목소리를 녹음해서 너한테 줄 거야.
자, 그런데 내가 읽어야 될
스크립트는 네가 만들도록 할 거고
내가 영상 파일을 전달을 해 주면은
MP4 파일을 전달해 주면 얼굴 없이
모션 애니메이션으로 영상을 만들어
줘. 자, 그렇기 때문에 우리
기획에서는 어떤 식으로 편집을 할지
그리고 어디에 어떤 신이 들어가야
될지를 정확히 명시를 해 줘야 돼.
자라고 이렇게 요청을 했고요. 어
타입스 쓰면 자 이렇게 잘 정리를 해
주니까 굉장히 유용합니다. 한번
요청을 넣어 볼게요. 자 이렇게
대기하면은 플랜이 바로 나오는 걸 볼
수가 있고요. 지금 한 5분 정도
걸렸거든요. 자 보면은 어 가장
중요한 건 우리가 폴더 구조로 보면은
우리가 원한 형태로 됐는지를
대강적으로 볼 수가 있어요. 그죠?
자 조금 이렇게 크게 해가지고 보면은
자 템플릿 템플릿은 뭐 당연히 우리가
기본적으로 여러 개의 프로젝트에
해당이 될 만한 요소들이 들어가는
거겠죠. 뭐 에이라던가 이렇게 뭐
색상이라던가 어떤 식으로 우리가 톤을
잡을지 뭐 이런 것들이 들어갈
거고요. 어 쉐우드 같은 경우에도
마찬가지일 거예요. 그죠? 공통 폰트
뭐 이런 것들이 들어가는 거고. 자,
프로젝트 폴더 안에다가 우리가 여러
개의 프로젝트를 진행하게 될 거다라고
얘기를 했기 때문에 여기에다 우리가
제목과 함께이 실제 우리 프로젝트에
필요한 부분들 자,이 컴포지션이 실제
우리 실제 우리가 영상을 어
프리뷰하는 하나의 프로덕션 파일이라고
생각하시면 돼요. 실제 우리 편집
툴에서도 컴포지션이라고 부르거든요.
자, 그래서 그런 것들이 각각
프로젝트별로 들어가야 된다. 자,
그래서 이번 플랜에서 사실 중요했던
거는 여러 개의 프로젝트를 우리가
형성해서 각각 독립적으로 운영을 할
수가 있냐였기 때문에 지금 정확히 된
거 같아요. 그래서 폴더 구조는
문제가 없는 거 같고. 뭐 왜 이렇게
했는지에 대한 설명들이 있죠. 그죠?
자, 그리고 자, 중요한 거. 자,
문서 템플릿. 자, 우리 기획이죠.
쉽게 말해서. 그래서 개요를 우리가
이렇게 넣을 거고 신약을 이렇게 넣을
거고 여기서 중요한 거는 우리가이
신별로 우리가 어떤 식으로 스크립트와
실제 우리가 모션 그래픽을 넣을
요소들을 정리를 할지가 중요하거든요.
그래서 그런게 잘 들어가 있는지
이렇게 봐 볼 거고 비주얼 연출하고서
레이아웃이 어떻게 돼 있는지 핵심
요소 모션 강조 이런 것들이 어떻게
들어가 있는지 우리가 어 다 확인할
수 있는 걸 볼 수가 있죠.음이
정도면 괜찮은 거 같아요. 자 진행
상태는 뭐 어떻게 돼도 사실 상관이
없는 거고 자 그래서 이런 식으로 쭉
된다라는 거죠. 자, 우리가 영상
프로젝트를 할 때 가장 중요한게
뭐냐면요. 첫 번째는 우리가 영상에
대한 정보를 어디까지 제공을 해 줄
건지. 자, 쉽게 말해서이 영상이라는
거는 어, FPS 그러니까 초당 어,
몇 개의 사진들이 연속으로 실행되냐.
그러니까 이제 쉽게 말하면 이제
영상인 거거든요. 그죠? 자, 그거를
우리가 얼마나 AI가 어떤 순간에
어느만큼 이해하고 보게 할지 우리가
그게 굉장히 중요하고. 근데 지금
우리가 하는 프로젝트는 사실 우리가
보이스만 사용할 거기 때문에 크게
중요하지는 않지만 만약에 여러분이
실제 얼굴이 나오는 부분까지 기획을
한다라고 하면은 여러분이 그 부분에
대해서 정보를 꼭 넣어 주는게 굉장히
중요합니다. 자, 그런데 우리 지금
컨텍스트 안에서 중요한 거는
뭐냐면요. 보이스. 자, 내가 무슨
이야기를 스크립트로 얘기를 하고
있는지를 우리가 이미 여기 안에
기획을 다 해 놓을 거기 때문에 어떤
순간에 그니까 몇 초쯤에 어떤
이야기를 하고 있는지를 대강적으로
감으로 잡을 수는 있지만 정확하게 알
수는 없어요. 네. 이거를 다
플레이를 해 보는게 아니기 때문에.
자, 그렇기 때문에 우리가 뭘 제공을
해 주면 좋냐면요. SLRT라는게
있습니다. 어떤 순간에 영상에서 어떤
이야기를 하고 있는지 캡션을
정확하게이 순간에 맞춰 가지고 제공을
해 주는 거거든요. 자, 그거는
우리가 다양한 방법으로 제공을 해 줄
수가 있는데 어, 위스퍼 프로젝트가
사실 오픈 소스이기 때문에 우리가
그거를 함께 하이퍼프레임이랑 합쳐
가지고 사용을 해 봐도 돼요. 자,
그래서 우리가 플랜을 리바이즈 할 때
뭐라고 할 거냐면은 캡션은 어떻게
MP4 파일을 제공을 하면은 내가
실제로 어떤 말을 어떤 순간에 했는지
알아야 될 거 같은데 위스퍼
프로젝트를 우리가 로컬해서 직접
인지하고 만들어내서 그 프로세스까지
자동할 수 있어라고 한번 요청을 해
보겠습니다. 자, 근데 저 같은
경우는 이미 이게 된다라는 걸
알아요. 아이퍼프레임은 사실이 위스버
프로젝트가 어 그냥이 위스퍼 CLI가
붙기만 하면 바로 되도록 이제 돼
있기 때문에 여러분이 그대로 사용을
하시면 되고요. 자, 그리고 또 뭐가
있냐면요.이 브르라고 있습니다.
부르라는이 프로그램인데 제가 지금
띄어 놓은게 자 이거를 다운받으시면
여러분이 한 달에 몇 시간 정도는
공절을 쓸 수가 있는데 1한시간
반인가 여기다 그냥 영상을 드래그 앤
드랍 하시면은 바로 엑스포트 하고서
여기서 SIT를 추출할 수 있는
방법이 있어요. 근데 이것도 똑같이
위스퍼를 써요. 예를 들어 제가
이렇게 영상을 임포트를 하면은 여기에
코리안이라고 돼 있고 여기 위스퍼라고
돼 있죠. 그죠? 위스퍼가 이제 제일
음성 인식이 제일 좋기 때문에
여러분이 그대로 위스퍼를 사용을 해
주시면 됩니다. 또는 제가 지금
여기다 요청을 한 것처럼 완전히
오토메이션을 해도 괜찮아요.
여러분의이 하드웨어가 충분히 받쳐
주기만 한다라고 하면은 로컬에서도
충분히 돌릴 수가 있어요. 자,
그러면은 이렇게 플랜이 업데이트 된
거를 볼 수 있죠. 자막 트랜스크립션
자동화 하면서 한 음성력 이렇게 돼
있는데 어, 여러 개의 모델이
존재합니다. 네. 스몰 미디엄 라지
있고요. 어차피이 3GB밖에 안 하기
때문에 그냥 라지 쓰시면 돼요. 어,
제가 해 보니까 라지 V3가 제일
좋습니다. 자, 그럼이 결과가 이걸
돌렸을 때 어떤 식으로 나오는지는
저희가 어, 함께 또 봐 보도록
할게요. 자, 위스퍼 라지 V3 모델
사용해 달라고 요청하고서 플랜 완전히
확정 짓도록 할게요. 자, 그리고
이렇게 마음에 들면은 자, 이렇게
플랜을 지금 벌써 몇 번을 저희가
고쳤죠? 정확히 뭐를 쓸지 저 고정
사용이 이렇게 돼 있는 거 이제 확인
저희가 100% 했고요. 완전히
마음에 들 때 우리가네 바이패스
퍼미션 모드로 바로 실행을 해 주면
된다라는 거예요. 그죠? 아무리 많이
시간이 걸리더라도 여러분이 플랜 같은
경우에는 어 계속 계속 수정을 해
주셔도 좋습니다. 그 괜찮아요. 어
계속 더 리파이닝 되는 거기 때문에
여러분이 어 시간을 충분히 갖고서
플랜을 작업을 해 주면은 해 주면 해
줄수록 좋다라고 여러분이 기억을 해
주시면 될 거 같아요. 자 그래서
바로 실행을 해 줄 거고요.이 어차피
한 번에 안 끝내요. 어 여러분이
하도 인터넷에서 딸깍딸깍 딸깍 소리를
들으니까 한 번에 돼야지 좋은 건줄
아는데 어 아닙니다. 한 번에 안
돼요. 한 번에 안 되는게 오히려
좋은 거예요.음 음. 거기서부터
여러분이 여러분이 원하는 형태로 깎아
나가는게 그게 소프트웨어 엔지니어링의
일부입니다. 그렇기 때문에 한 번에
될 거라고 애초에 생각을 하지를
마세요. 그냥 운이 좋은 거예요.
만약에 한 번에 어 내가 생각했던게
그대로 나와 버리네 안다고 하면은.
자, 그러면 이제 폴더 구조가 이렇게
만들어진 걸 볼 수가 있죠. 그리고
우리 업데이트가 됐기 때문에 이제는
8구조 이렇게 바로 볼 수가
있습니다. 그죠? 자, 그러면 우리가
기획한다던 대로 그대로 플랜이
나왔는지 플랜이 구현이 됐는지 우리가
확인을 해 주면 되고요. 자, 그럼
여기서부터 우리가 뭘 하면 되냐?
자, 첫 번째 프로젝트 우리가 한번
그러면은 테스트를 진행을 해
보겠다라고 가정을 해 볼 건데. 자,
그럼 여기서부터 뭐 하면 되냐? 이제
첫 번째 주제를 우리가 기획을 해
보면 되겠죠. 그죠? 자, 기획까지
전부 다 예아한테 맡기기로 했고 그
자체가 우리 플랜에 있었기 때문에
토픽을 일단 한번 정해 보도록
할게요. 우리 되게 쉽게 한번가
보겠습니다. 1분 내외로 에이전틱
AI에 대해서 설명하는 영상을 기획해
줘. 모션 그래픽이 적절하게 들어갈
수 있도록 통계라던가 아니면 조금 더
비주얼하게 우리가 보여줄 수 있는
요소들이 기획에 함께 들어가 있으면은
좋겠어라고 한번 이제 대강적으로
얘기를 해 보겠습니다. 자, 그리고
이거는 우리가이 폴더 구조에서 봤던
것처럼 실제 우리 스크립트 파일에
들어갈 거기 때문에 어, 그거는
저희가 어, 바로 그냥 만들어 가지고
그 안에서 수정을 시키도록 할게요.
네. 그거는 이제 우리가
플랜점.md를 계속해서 수정해 가면
되니까요. 그죠? 자, 플래닝
나왔고요. 한번 봐 볼게요. 자,
신약은 1번부터 6번 신까지 지금
있는 거를 볼 수가 있고요. 자,
어떤 식으로 지금 비주얼 컨셉을
가져갔는지 이렇게 설명이 되는 걸로
볼 수가 있어요. 그래서 큰 타이오
캐스케이드가 있고 뭐 좌우 비교
다이아그램, 뭐 4분, 카드 그리드,
스태어 등장, 카운트업 숫자, 그리고
막대 그래프 좋아요. 아이콘, 그리고
짧은 어, 라벨 캐러셀 뭐 이런
것들이 있고 음, CTA까지 이렇게
있도록 기획을 한 거를 볼 수가
있습니다. 어, 제가 딱 원했던 그런
느낌인 거 같아요. 대강적으로 저는
이런 차트가 꼭 있으면 좋겠다라고
생각을 했는데 일단 이건 우리가 한번
그려 봐야지 어떤 느낌인지 볼 거
같습니다. 우리가 기획을 했던 대로
이렇게 신별로 나눠진 거를 볼 수가
있고요. 자, 이렇게 읽으면 된다라고
하는게 바로 우리 스크립트입니다.
자, 그다음에 자, 여기도 이렇게
스크립트가 될 거고요. 여기도 이렇게
스크립트가 될 거고 우리 6번까지
전부 다 읽으면은 돼요. 자, 그러면
여기에서 이제 여러분이 결정을
해야겠죠? 자,이 에이전팅 룹에서
여기까지는 자동화가 됐죠. 그죠?
전부 다 이제 AI가 작업을 했는데
이거 실제로 읽는 것도 어 AI가 할
건지 그러니까 뭐 일렙스 같은 거 써
가지고 또는 내가 읽는 거는 할 건지
그러면서 뭐 얼굴은 더 보여 줄 건지
뭐 이런 것들을 여러분이 어 결정을
해 주시면 됩니다. 저 같은 경우는
이제 제가 직접 읽을 거고요. 자
이거 오수오 포켓이라는 걸 써 가지고
제가 한번 제 자신을 레코딩을 하고
그거를 제가 컵 편집만 해 가지고
한번 넣어 보도록 할게요. 네.
천천히 한번 읽어 보도록 하겠습니다.
자, 그리고 제가 녹화한 거를 자,
이렇게 컵 편집만 제가 따로 해
가지고 따로 추출을 했어요. 그리고
얘를 실행을 해 보면은 한 번 물으면
한 번 답하지만 에이전트 계는 스스로
계획을 세우고 도구를 쓰고
>> 뭐 이런 식으로 이제 말하는 거를
제가 녹음을 했거든요. 그럼 이거를
우리가 실제 우리 플랜이 위치에다가
옮기면 되겠죠. 자, 소스에다 그래서
이렇게 옮겨 놨습니다. 그죠? 자,
그러면은 우리가 이제 이거를 돌릴
준비가 된 거예요. 돌릴 준비가
됐는데 지금 우리가 어,이 플랜에서
얘기를 했던 것처럼 어차피 우리
기획대로 우리가 읽었어도 이미 시간이
차이가 나요. 지금 45초 만에
끝났고 영상은 실제로는 우리가 기획한
건 1분이었는데이 정확한 우리가
말했던 위치를 AI가 알 수
있어야지만이 애니메이션과 우리
보이스를 매칭을 시킬 수가 있겠죠.
그죠? 자, 그래서 우리가 위스퍼
같은게 필요한 겁니다. 레코딩.
MP4 파일을 제공을 했으니까
위스퍼로 캡션을 만들고 캡션을 검증해
줘. 자라고 한번 요청을 해 볼게요.
자, 이거 왜 검증해 달라고
하냐면요.이 리스퍼로 돌렸을 때
특히나 한국어 같은 경우에는 어,
조금 이상한 표현들이 있을 때가
있어요. 그때 어, LRM으로 우리가
한번 파악을 하고서 어, 이건 이런
말이 아니라 어, 이런 말일 거
같은데라고 한 번 더 유출을 하도록
하면은 조금 더 완성도로 우리가 많이
올릴 수가 있습니다. 자, 조금
기다리니까 트랜스크립션이 다 된 거를
볼 수가 있고요. 몇 가지 단어 잘못
인식된 것들을 어, 이렇게 바꾸면
어떠냐라고 저희한테 물어보는 거 볼
수가 있죠. 자, 패치를 해 달라고
했습니다. 그래서 자, 그래서
AI한테 항상이 같은 컨텍스트 우리가
지금 알고 있는 것과 AI가 알고
있는게 같은 컨텍스트 안에 있는게
굉장히 중요해요. 그런 이유에서
마찬가지로 지금 이번에 생성된
트랜스크립트.제이스 그죠? 자, 이런
식으로 나오거든요. 자, 몇 초에
정확히 내가 어떤 말을 했는지 그죠?
자, 이걸 우리가 제공해 주는 이유가
뭐예요? AI가 바라보고 있는이
데이터와 그러니까이 영상 그리고
보이스라는이 데이터 제가 듣고 있는이
보이스가 똑같이 매칭이 될 수 있도록
같은 컨텍스트 안에서 우리가 협업을
할 수 있도록 우리가 정보를 충분히
제공을 해 주는 겁니다. 이게 첫
번째 레슨이에요. 자, 이거는
여러분이 어떤 프로젝트를 진행해도
똑같아요. 뭐 웹사이트를 만든다라고
하면은 플레이라이트 같은 걸 사용해서
영상이라던가 사진을 찍어서 AI가
그거를 다시 주입해 가지고 생각하도록
하다고 이미지를 제작을 한다라고
하면은 그 이미지를 생성을 하고 그걸
다시 집어넣어서 실제 어떤 부분에
어떤 요소가 있는지 파악을 하게 한
다음에 그거를 본인이 스스로
이터레이션 하도록 한다거나 우리가
대충 그냥 영상이라던가 아니면은 음성
파일을 던졌을 때 AI가 우리가 지금
듣고 우리가 보는 거랑 똑같은 문맥을
갖고서 그 파일을 파악할 수가
없다라는 거예요. 그럴 수가
없다라면은 우리가 최대한 우리가 지금
바라보고 있는이 정보와 비슷한
포지션에 있을 수 있도록 우리가
충분한 정보를 어떤 형태로든 제공을
해 줘야 된다는 거죠. 자, 그래서
이렇게 디테일하게 우리가 어떤
부분에서 어떤 이야기를 하고 있는지
AI가 완전히 이해할 수 있는
포맷으로 우리가 정보를 준다라고
하면은 훨씬 더 정확한 협업이 될
수가 있는 거고 여러분이 아무리 어떤
특정 파일을 넣어 놔도 굉장히
원론적인 답변밖에 얻을 수 없는
이유도 그런 부분에 있습니다. 그래서
그거를 꼭 여러분이 깊게 파고 들어야
되고요. 제가 옛날에는 이제
프레임워크를 항상 고를 때 디벨로
익스প DX를 중요시 하라고 제가
항상 말씀을 드렸는데 요즘 말씀을
드린 건 AX를 중요시 하라고
합니다. 어 여러분이 일반적으로 알고
있는 AI 트랜스포메이션이 아니고요.
AI 익스피리언스 그러니까 AI가
우리 프롬프트를 듣고서 작업하기 편한
환경 그거를 제공해 줄 수 있는
기술을 여러분이 꼭 사용을 해 주셔야
됩니다. 그래서 저도 스택이 굉장히
많이 바뀌었고요. 그 루이 에이전틱
루이 다치지 않는 프레임워크를
여러분이 고른다라고 하면은 여러분이
해야 되는 일이 너무 많이 생기고
그리고 그 자체가 병목이 돼요. 자,
그러면은이 정도 이제 충분한
컨텍스트가 생겼으니까 자, 여기서부터
또 애가 작업을 할 수가 있겠죠?
자, 일단 진행해 주라고 하겠습니다.
자,이 컴포지션 이제 만들기 시작을
할 건데 어, 한 번에 좀 잘되지
않았으면 좋겠어요. 그래야지 우리가
좀 더 배울게 있을 것 같으니까
기다려 볼게요. 자, 프리뷰가
나왔습니다. 한번 봐 볼게요. 기존
AI는 한 번 물으면 한 번 답하지만
에이전틱 계는 스스로 계약을 세우고
도구를 쓰고 결과를 확인하면서 목표를
끝낼 때까지 반복합니다. 에이전틱
에아의네 가지 핵심은 이렇습니다.
목표분해. 가트너는 2028년이면
기업 의사 결정의 15%를 AI
에이전트가 자동으로 처리할 거라고
예측했습니다. 시장 규모는
2030년까지 연평균 45%씩
성장한다고 합니다. 이미 고객응대
시장 조사처럼 사람의 하루 치일을 몇
분 만에 끝내는 에이전트들이 일하고
있습니다. 이제 AI는 다 파는
도구가 아니라 동료입니다. 어, 지금
생각보다 어, 저는이
스타일이 완전 좀 깨지기를 조금
기대를 했는데 음, 그래야지 이제 좀
에이전팅 루프를 좀 보여 드리고 싶어
가지고 자, 근데 모션 그래픽의
적용은 굉장히 잘 된 거 같아요.
자, 근데이 보이스 오버랑 조금 지금
타이밍이 어긋나죠? 현재 지금 우리
보이스 오버랑이 모션 그래픽의
타이밍이 어긋나고 있어. 자, 왜
그런지 확인해 주고. 자, 그리고이
모션 그래픽이 우리가 의도한 대로
나왔는지 AI가 에이전틱하게 확인할
수 있는 루프를 기획을 해주고 어떤
옵션들이 있는지 예를 들어서
스크린샷인지 아니면 플레이라이트라든지
이런 것들을 우리가 어떻게 활용할 수
있는지 알려 줘. 자, 이렇게 요청을
해 보도록 할게요. 자, 왜 이렇게
얘기를 하냐면요. 만약에이 모션
그래픽이 조금 이상하게 나왔으면
저희가 조금 더 효율적으로 이걸
확인해 볼 수가 있을 건데. 자,
이것도 마찬가지예요. 자, 이거는
이제 소프트웨어 영역에서 오지 않은
사람들에게 굉장히 좀 의아할 수가
있는 부분인데 우리가 수정한 코드와
결과물은 같은게 아니에요. 어, 이게
무슨 말이냐면은 되긴 말일 수가
있는데 우리가 수정한 코드는 굉장히
큰 부분에 엄청난 일부분이고요.
결과물은이 모든 것들을 다 빌드를
해서 보여 주는게 결과물이란
말이에요. 그죠? 자, 그래서 우리가
수정한이 굉장히 작은 부분이 우리의
의도는 그 작은 영역만 수정이 되기를
바라고서 했을 수도 있겠지만 그거에
대한 굉장히 많은 의존성들이 함께
영향을 받을 수가 있다는 거죠.
그래서 결과물을 우리가 의도하지 않은
채로 완전히 바꿔 낼 수가 있다는
겁니다. 자, 그래서 여러분이 어,
코드를 내가 이렇게 수정하라고 해
가지고 수정을 했는데 왜 결과물이
우리가 얘기했던 거랑 달라라고 하면서
불평을 할게 아니라요. AI한테도
보여 줘야 돼요. 이렇게 수정을
했더니 지금 이렇게 됐는데 그게 네가
생각한게 맞아라고 네가 확인을 할 수
있도록 한번 네가 그 루프를 돌려
봐라는 걸여 여러분이 꼭 꼭 제시를
해 줘야지. AI도 자기가 수정한
거에 대한 결과물이 어떻게 나왔고 어
이게 내가 생각한 거 아닌데라는 걸
이제 판단을 하고 그러면은 어디까지
우리가이 스코프를 늘려서 봐야
될까라는 거를 자동적으로인지를 할
수가 있게 된다라는 거죠. 자 근데
이번 프로젝트는 우리가 영상이기
때문에 그 영상들을 우리가 의도한
대로 그러니까 우리가 코드로 우리가이
영상의 모션 그래픽들을 만들었지만
그게 실제로 우리가 생각한 대로 모션
그래픽이 나는지를 확인할 수 있도록이
루프를 또 돌려 준다는 거죠. 자,
그래서 AI가 수정한 것과이 결과물에
갭이 생기는 건 당연한 겁니다.
그거는 개발자들끼리도 그래요. 원래
그래. 원래 그렇기 때문에 여러분이
불평을 하면 안 됩니다. 불평할게
아니라 AI가 스스로 검증할 수 있는
루프를 여러분이 직접 만들어 줘야
된다는 거죠. 자, 제가 요청한 거에
대해서 유약을 하면은 세 개의
게이트를 이렇게 추천을 해 줬는데 첫
번째로는 레이아웃 스냅샷이라 해가지고
하이퍼프레임에서 프레임별로 스냅샷을
그러니까 스크린샷을 찍을 수 있는
기능을 제공을 해 주거든요. 그럼
그걸 찍어 가지고 실제로 우리가
의도한 컴포넌트들이 의도한 위치에
있는지 우리가 확인을 자동으로 하도록
할 수가 있고요. 딱 단어가 나오는
어떤 순간에 우리가 어 싱크가 맞는지
두 번째는 이제 확인을 해야 되고 세
번째로는 처음부터 끝까지 전부 다
실행을 해 가지고 렌더링 직전에
우리가 베리피케이션을 하는 거를
추천을 한다라고 얘기를 하고 있어요.
그죠? 자, 그럼 여기까지 되면은요.
그냥 단순히 어, 코드를 썼으니까 다
됐어요. 확인해 주세요라고 하는게
아니라 코드를 쓰고 한번 자기가
실행을 해서 서버를 그래서 서버에서
다시 확인을 하고 어, 이거는
잘못됐네라고 파악을 한 다음에 다시
수정을 하고 원래 플랜에 가까워질 수
있도록 계속 무한에서 루프를 돈
다음에 AI 입장에서 더 확신이 될
때 어,이 정도면 이제 됐다라고 했을
때 저희한테 어, 확인해 주세요라고
요청을 하도록 할 수가 있다라는
거죠. 자, 이루프 같은 경우에는
거의 플레이라이트 MCP가 나올
때부터 제가 이제 계속 말씀을 드리던
건데 이렇게 계속 주입을 여러분이 해
주셔야지만이 완성도를 AI가 계속
지속적으로 올리도록 할 수가 있다는
겁니다. 어떤 프로젝트가 됐든요.
이게 불가능한 프레임워크라면요. 이게
가능한 프레임워크로 여러분이 대체를
해 주셔야 돼요. 자, 수장이
완료됐다고 해서 한번 다시 실행을 해
보도록 할게요.
>> 지키면 알아서 끝까지 해 주는 시대.
이게 바로 에이전틱 AI입니다. 기존
AI는 한 번 물으면 한 번 답하지만
에이전틱 AI는 스스로 계약을 세우고
도구를 쓰고 결과를 확인하면서 목표를
끝낼 때까지 반복합니다. 에이전트의네
가지 핵심은 이렇습니다. 목표 분해.
둘째 도구 사용, 셋째 자기 검증
넷째 장기 기업. 가트너는
2028년이면 기업 의사 결정의
15%를 AI 에이전트가 자동으로
처리할 거라고 예측했습니다. 시장
규모는 2030년까지 연평균 45%씩
성장한다고 합니다. 이미 고객대,
코드 작성, 시장 조사처럼 사람의
하루 치일을 몇 분 만에 끝내는
에이전트들이 일하고 있습니다. 이제
AI는 다 파는 도구가 아니라
동료입니다. 자, 그래서 우리가
반복적으로 알아서 개선하도록 우리가
루프를 만들어 주는 것만으로도 저희가
굳이 어, 몇 분 몇 초에 이런게
들어가야 되지 잘못됐어라고 얘기할
필요 없이 알아서 개선을 해 나가는
거를 확인할 수가 있어요. 그죠?
자,이 루프를 만들어 주는게 굉장히
중요하다는 겁니다. 자, 그러면은
마지막에 지금 제일 중요한게
뭐냐면요. 우리가 정말 많은이 소통을
했잖아요. 그죠? 그리고 많은
문제들을 해결했단 말이에요. 그러면은
어 여기까지가 그러면은 한 판이다라고
결정을 하고 지금까지 우리가 작업을
하면서 어려웠던 점들 그리고 문제
있었던 점들 이런 걸 전부 다
정리해서 우리가 다음에는 한 번에
수월하게 작업을 할 수 있도록 문서로
상세하게 어떤 식으로 우리가 어 모션
그래픽을 만들어야 되는지
하이퍼프레임을 사용을 해야 되는지
정리를 해 줘. 가장 중요한 포인트는
앞으로 우리가 똑같은 실수를 하지
않도록 하고 앞으로는 한 번에 완성도
높은 결과물이 나오도록 하는게
포인트야. 자라고 이렇게 얘기를 해
주면요. 여러분이 어떤를 쓰던간에이
메모리 파일들이 있을 거고 룰
파일들이 있을 거란 말이에요. 그죠?
그런 부분에 알아서 우리가 지금까지
어 여러 번이 에어를 스티어링을 해서
그러니까 우리가 방향성을 정해 주면서
결과물을 얻어야 됐었던 요소들을이
AI한테 이번 다음번에는 한 번에
우리가 원하는 결과물목까지 나올 수
있도록이 과정을 전부 다 정리해서 어
이렇게 하면 돼라고 우리가 정확하게
말해 줄 수 있도록 정리를 한다라는
거죠. 자, 이렇게 해놓고 나면
우리가 첫 번째 영상을 만드는
데까지는 시간이 오래 걸렸지만 이제
두 번째 우리가 영상을 만들려고
한다라고 하면은 자, 어, 우리가
이런 과정이 있었고 이런 과정 속에서
우리가 이런 문제들이 생길 수가
있으니까 내가 말하는 대로 순서대로
이렇게 딱 작업을 해 주면 돼라고
우리가 명확한 인스트럭션을 줄 수가
있다라는 거예요. 자, 그러면은
우리가 지금까지는이 루프를 에이전팅
루프를 클로징을 하려고 굉장히 큰
노력을 했지만 한번이 루프를 클로징을
하고 나면은 우리가 그 루프가
무한하게 돌도록 만들어 낼 수가
있다라는 겁니다. 자, 그러면 이뿐만
아니라 여러분이 또 작업할 수 있는
것들이 굉장히 많이 있어요. 예를
들어서 우리 뭐이 스크립트의
완성도라든가 아니면은이 애니메이션에
대한이 테마 같은 거라든가 여러분이
개선하고 싶은 것들 있잖아요. 어,
이건 조금 애이 냄새한데. 어, 이건
좀 내 스타일이 아닌데. 어, 이건
좀 디테일에 부족한데. 그죠? 그걸
여러분이 그냥 아이 뭐 이렇게 아이가
못하라고 불평할게 아니라 어 이제는
여러분들이 이해했겠죠. 그거는 진짜
멍청한 소리입니다. 여러분이 원하는
완성도가 될 때까지 직접 휴먼 인더
루브로이 에이전팅 룹을 클로징을 할
수 있도록 최대한 노력을 한 다음에
그 프레임 안에서 다음 프로세스들을
돌리게 되면은 AI가 그때부턴
잘한다는 겁니다. 그래서 계속 우리가
얘기를 하는게 주니어 개발자 주니어들
다루는 거랑 똑같다라고 얘기를 하는
거예요. 우리가 원하는이 AI를
쉐이핑을 해 나가는 거죠. 자,
그래서 제가 오늘 말씀드리고 싶었던
이야기는이 이야기고요.이 스토리가
그냥 하이퍼프레임뿐만 아니라
여러분들이 앞으로 하는이 프로젝트에
큰 도움이 됐으면 좋겠습니다. 자,
제가 오늘 준비한 영상 여기까지고요.
영상이 좋았던 구독과 좋아요, 알림
설정 그리고 댓글에 하이보까지 꼭 해
주시면 제가 다음 영상을 제작하는데
더 큰 도움이 됩니다. 자, 그럼
다음 영상에 뵙도록 할게요.
감사합니다. 쏘지.